- Hi everyone, Sal Khan here.
Welcome to the Homeroom
with Sal livestream.
We have a very, very
exciting conversation today
with Jennifer Doudna,
the 2020 Nobel prize winner in chemistry.
For what has often been described as
one of the most important discoveries
in the history of biology
or maybe in the history of science.
And we'll talk about why that is.
It could actually forever change
even what it means to be human.
But before we go into that,
I will give my standard announcements
a reminder that we are and
not-for-profit Khan Academy.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to Khan academy.org/donate.
Donations of all size,
make a huge difference.
Also wanna give a special shout
out to several organizations
that stepped up, especially
during COVID when they realized
more people were depending on us.
And we were running at a deficit.
Special thanks to Bank of America, AT&T,
Google.org, Novartis, Fastly.
And it was just announced
yesterday General Motors
for very, very generous support
to allow us to help millions
of y'all keep learning
this year and last year.
Also wanna remind you that
there's a podcast version
of this live stream, wherever
you get your podcasts
Homeroom with Sal, the podcast.
With that, I'm very, very
excited to introduce Jennifer
who is a, you are the li Ka-shing
chancellor's chair professor
at the department of chemistry
and department of
molecular and cell bio...
You have a very long title.
Department of cell molecular biology
at the University of California, Berkeley.
You got the 2020 Nobel prize in chemistry
for your work with CRISPR.
Thank you so much for joining us.
- Thanks for inviting me
Sal, great to be here.
- Those of y'all watching
who have not heard of CRISPR
this will be, I predict a
hundred years in the future.
All of the other craziness
of 2020 will kind of
not be remembered as much
as the work that Jennifer
and her colleagues have done
over the last several years in CRISPR.
Jennifer, for those of you
who are unfamiliar with it
what's kind of the headline
or the cliff notes version
of what CRISPR is and why it's important?
- Well, I guess I would start by saying
it's a technology for genome editing.
What does that mean?
Well, it's a tool that
scientists are using to make
precise changes to the DNA
in a cell or a whole organism
that can lead to alterations
in the genetic makeup
of the cell or the resulting organisms.
So we're, ah, we've got the video here.
We're seeing the CRISPR system in action.
So it's a protein that purple blob
with a little zip code molecule in it
a piece of RNA that allows binding
to a 20 letter sequence
in the DNA of a cell.
And so you can see the
guide RNA marking the site
and then DNA getting cut.
That's the T activity of CRISPR.
And what that does is to
induce a DNA repair pathway
in cells that allows cells
to alter the DNA sequence
at that precise position.
And in the example, we
just saw in the video
there was insertion of a new piece of DNA
that could allow cells
to acquire a new gene
or even a new set of genes.
And this is all now being
controlled by scientists.
So we can manipulate genes
in ways that were previously
very difficult or impossible.
- Yeah, and for those watching
who didn't fully appreciate
how powerful what some
of what you just said is
obviously are, I mean,
we're living systems
everything else is...
All living systems have DNA.
You have these long sequences
of DNA, parts of them.
Those are individual genes
that can code for proteins
or sets of proteins.
And now using CRISPR,
y'all have introduced
a technology that can help us edit DNA.
Before I go into all of
the implications positive
and potentially ones that
we have to wonder about,
I'm curious about how your pathway
to kind of discovering this.
When did it first dawn on you
that something like this could happen?
And how hard or easy was
it to get to the place
that you got to?
- Well, you know Sal,
what I love about CRISPR,
one of the things is the origin story.
Because this is really
a technology that came
out of a fundamental
curiosity driven project.
It was small science, not big science.
It was science being done by
a handful of laboratories.
And in our own lab at University
of California, Berkeley
we were investigating
CRISPR, which was originally
discovered to be a
bacterial immune system,
a way that bacteria can
detect and destroy viruses.
And when I heard about
this from my colleague,
Jillian Banfield at Berkeley,
probably a dozen years ago now
I was fascinated.
I wondered, well, how does that work?
And so we began investigating it.
- People have known about
CRISPR for some time.
If this stands for
Clustered Regularly Interspaced
Short Palindromic Repeats.
But really what that is is these bacteria
would have these sequences of
what would it be DNA or RNA-
- DNA.
- DNA, and it would have pieces of kind of
ancient other viruses in it.
And so it would use those as kind of
that tagging location sequence
the way that you just described
in that previous visual
to kind of cut viral DNA,
is that what it was doing?
- Yes, that's right.
And by the way not necessarily ancient
pieces of virus either.
This is a system that works in real time.
So during an infection, a
bacterial cell could acquire
a DNA sequence from a virus
and then use it as the template
to make a guide RNA molecule that allows
this kind of searching that
you're seeing going on here
by the CAS9 protein.
So this is a system that started
as a fundamental biology project.
But once Emmanuel
Charpentier our collaborator
in our lab figured out
how the CAS9 protein works
as a DNA cleaver, we could
see how it could be harnessed
as a genome editing technology.
And that's really, what's taken off
over the last eight years.
- When did you first learn about CRISPR
and that bacteria were using it
in order to be your
viral defense mechanism
and it dawned on you that,
hey, maybe that could be used to edit DNA?
When was this and then how
long before you started
making some significant progress on that?
- I think I first heard
about CRISPR in the mid 2000s
from Jillian Banfield, at Berkeley
who was researching this in bacteria.
She was looking at DNA
sequences in bacteria.
And she was one of the first laboratories
to realize that bacteria were
acquiring DNA and storing it
in their own genetic material in real time
in response to viral infection,
sort of a fascinating observation.
And at that time it was a hypothesis
that this might be some
kind of immune system.
And that's really where we got involved.
- Initially, were you like,
this is like a 5% chance
of this actually leading to anything?
Did people think that you were kind of
going down on a wild goose chase?
Or was it apparent pretty early
that no, this is a big idea?
- Little of both, I guess.
I certainly felt like it was
a very interesting biological
phenomenon that I wanted to pursue.
At the same time, I was a
little bit nervous about
using biomedical research
funding to work on this
because it wasn't entirely
clear where it was headed
in terms of ultimate outcomes.
And I can remember getting
a few strange looks
at scientific meetings when I first began
talking about our work on CRISPR
because at that time almost
nobody had heard of it.
And it sounded like a real
niche area of biology.
- What was the moment
and when was the moment
where you said, oh my God,
this works, this works?
One of my favorite papers
which I'm sure you're
very familiar with is
Watson and Crick paper, where
they found the structure
of the double helix structure of DNA.
Which is a one and a 1/2
page paper at the end
I think they say something like
it has not passed our attention,
the implications of this word.
When was that moment for you?
When did it happen and
what did it just feel like?
And how did you know
that you'd kind of gotten to something?
Well, it was somewhat of
a continuum, I would say.
Towards the end of the 2000s,
we were working on
various different aspects
of the CRISPR system and bacteria.
Mostly doing biochemical
experiments in the lab,
meaning working with
purified proteins and RNAs
and DNA molecules to
figure out the chemistry
of how they work together.
And then that work really culminated
in the work that we published in 2012
where we described the way
that the CAS9 protein works
as an RNA guided molecular
scissors that can cut DNA
at a desired place.
And importantly, that we
as scientists could control
where the cutting
happens by programming it
with these molecules of RNA.
And I think for us that was really
the publication that, where
we were able to point out
that this could be used
as a gene editing tool.
And I just wanna make sure I understand.
Actually, you can move over a little bit
I think to the right, your camera is-
- I'm drifting-
- Much better.
Just to make sure I understand
what makes the science
so it makes sense to me that you have
this kind of protein enzyme
complex that has a strand of RNA
on it and that RNA can find
the complimentary part of DNA.
And then this protein is able to cut there
and maybe in another place as well,
maybe based on another RNA strand.
How do you insert?
I mean, in that visual we saw
that there was that step where...
Does the DNA just kind of float in?
And if you put the right
enzymes, it'll attach.
How does that insertion work?
Or was that part easy,
did people already know
how to do that?
- No, not that part is not easy.
And in fact that's a great question, Sal
'cause it really gets to the
heart of this technology.
Because importantly, CRISPR is a cutter,
it's a cutting technology.
And the actual genome
editing happens in the cell
when the cell uses its repair proteins
to fix the broken DNA.
So in that example that
we saw that illustrates
how in a cell, a broken piece
of DNA could be repaired
by inserting a new section of DNA.
And there are whole sets
of proteins and cells
that are responsible for
that kind of chemistry.
And in truth, we don't fully understand
how to control that reaction in the cells
but we know that cells are very good
at detecting broken DNA and fixing it.
And there are different
ways to kind of try to
encourage cells to do the DNA
repair in a particular way
such as inserting a section
of DNA to make that kind of
a desired genome edit.
- No, the thing we
always like to emphasize
whenever I make a video
on chemistry or biology
at Khan Academy, in textbooks,
they kind of make you
believe that these proteins
have brains of their own
and they know exactly
where to zero in on but these are these
thermodynamic chemical
systems where things are
just constantly vibrating and
colliding with each other.
And some of those collisions stick
if the right kind of
things can get close enough
with not too much energy
to the right things
and enough energy too sometimes.
And so it's all of this
random stuff happening.
And so, yeah, definitely I can
conceptualize how the enzyme
and the RNA they're part of this complex.
At some point they're gonna run into
the right part of the DNA they cut
and then how do we get that
right DNA sequence in there?
And it sounds like it is
a little bit stochastic.
You could have some of
the DNA might repair,
but if you are able to kind
of have those DNA fragments
around and the presence
of the right enzymes
some of that will get stuck in as well.
- Yes, exactly.
And so, because of that
scientists are trying to
manipulate the conditions of
these gene editing experiments
so that we get the desired outcome.
Whether it's insertion
of a new section of DNA
or disruption of a small sequence
such as a single base pair.
And there's already a lot
of questions coming in.
I think a lot of people
are able to extrapolate
what this could do for
better or for worse maybe
in certain circumstances.
So from Facebook,
Michelle Furry is asking,
can this be done to adults?
Can the DNA editing be done
to adults or only to embryos?
Which it goes to this, can
it be done for somatic cells
which we have trillions of
or do you have to kind of
get something at the embryonic stage?
- Great question, Michelle.
So, the answer is that the
vast majority of genome editing
for people is going to be, in my opinion,
certainly for the foreseeable future
will be in adults or kids,
but certainly not in embryos.
And so you might wonder,
well, how does that work?
And typically it would be a treatment
where cells that can regenerate
or even create a new tissue
would be the ones being edited.
So I'll give you an example.
Sickle cell disease is a
well-known genetic disorder
of the blood, that results from
a single mutation in a gene
that encodes one of
this essential proteins
for carrying oxygen in
our red blood cells.
And so with sickle cell
disease, CRISPR can be used
to make correcting mutations
just in those cells
that give rise to new red blood cells.
And so that's a way that
therapy can be used in patients
in a way where it impacts the
patient, but not anybody else.
- And how is that done?
Is that done by introducing the enzyme
directly into the cell somehow?
Or does it have like a
kind of a harmless virus
that can kind of take it in?
How do you introduce it
into the somatic cells,
the body cells, these
potentially trillions of cells
that might be involved here?
- Yeah, well right now
the way it's being done
is by taking those blood precursor cells
we call them blood stem
cells out of a patient
and doing the genome
editing in the laboratory.
The CRISPR protein and it's
guiding RNA can be introduced
in different ways.
It can be put in as a directly
assembled molecular complex
of the protein and the RNA.
Or it can be put in, as you mentioned Sal,
using what we call a vector, for example
a virus that can encode those materials.
- So y'all will take the stem cells out.
And I mean, you're able to do it like
you're not doing one cell at a time
you're able to do like
globs of it, I guess.
I think that's a technical
term, right, globs?
- Well, it sounds kind of technical.
- By either with the
virus or introducing it.
I am curious because I know
I've had you could tell
people, I hang out with,
I've had debates with my
friends overnight about
when you do it the way you just described
it affects that one individual.
And hopefully it cures them of sickle cell
which could be a very bad
disease, so that's huge.
There's the other possibility
of you're going to the germline.
You're either going directly to an embryo
or you're going to the cells that produce
the sperms and the eggs.
And then that in theory,
you're effecting the gene pool.
And so one question is, is that doable?
And then what are your thoughts on that?
Because there's a possibility
of removing sickle cell
from the gene pool entirely.
But where do you see the
puts and takes there?
- What you just described
is what we call germline
or germ cell editing.
And we call them germ cells
because they're literally
able to give rise
to many more cells that
are of a particular type.
You can create a whole organism,
like a whole human being.
And the reason that that is in my view
a much more profound use of CRISPR is that
it creates what we call a
heritable change in the DNA.
So it affects not just the individual,
but all of their kids
and their kids' kids.
Now, if you could remove a harmful gene
from the human population
and that would obviously take time
but you could in principle
do this using genome editing.
It could be argued that
there might be cases
where that would be desirable.
But I think right now, for many reasons
some of them are technical.
And of course there are
many ethical implications.
I think most scientists
feel that that is not
an appropriate use of
CRISPR in humans right now.
And that we should focus
on somatic cell editing.
- And this is already leading to,
I remember being at a conference
and someone was talking about this
there are already people
being treated for sickle cell
because of this.
- Right, it's extraordinary.
It's very exciting for all
of us working in the field
to see this work already
benefiting patients.
And we know there will
be many more to benefit
in the future.
- Absolutely, and on the ethics of it,
you have this question from Facebook,
Jeffrey Kurtzberg is asking
who should decide the ethics
of the science, just
because we can, should we
the butterfly effect may not
be a strong enough analogy.
And I think what he's referring
to is you can edit one gene.
It seems to do one thing, but
these are complex systems.
And obviously there was that,
I don't know if you folks know
there was that case in
China where a scientist
kind of went rogue used this
technology to edit an embryo
to have a more resistance towards AIDS.
And actually I read that
scientist was put in prison
because of the questionable
ethics of this.
So one, it seems like
the cat's out of the bag,
this is something that can be
done by scientists anywhere
you don't need billions of
dollars of capital to do CRISPR.
Who do you think should decide it?
What do you think is going to happen is
if there's countries, jurisdictions
where people don't care.
How can we regulate this type of thing?
- I think so, first of all,
thanks for the question, Jeffrey.
I think the situation with CRISPR
is in a way analogous to what we see
for a number of types of technologies
whether they're in the biological sciences
or in technology computing
with for example,
artificial intelligence
where the question is
the technology is powerful.
There are many opportunities to use it
to do things that will
be beneficial to humanity
but there also are risks.
And how do we control those risks
and who decides about uses?
And I guess for me with CRISPR,
I feel strongly that it has to,
that those decisions
really do need to be made
by all the stakeholders that are involved.
So in the end, that
kind of means all of us
and that will require scientists to engage
and discuss the science itself
and kind of the way the technology works.
And also to work closely with regulators
and all sorts of groups that
are thinking about in this case
how genome editing could
impact people in the future
so that we can make responsible decisions.
And that sounds hard and it is.
But I think a way to start is by engaging
the scientific community globally
to think about this and
work on it together.
And I've been actually very
pleased over the last few years
that in discussions that I started
with my colleagues back
in, I think it was 2015
we've been able to engage
with now the World Health
Organization, with UNESCO
and with many of the scientific
societies around the world
to come together.
There've been many conferences
and committees that have been
convened to look into this.
And we now have, I think,
a very good framework
for using CRISPR in different
settings going forward.
- And there's tons of
questions are coming in
'cause this is such a fascinating topic.
I'm curious and there's several
questions along this lines.
Well, one beyond sickle cell
where do you think is the next obvious?
Sickle cell seems, seems
it is very compelling
'cause it's one mutation,
as you mentioned.
It seems to have a clear negative
if you can fix it, clear positive.
What are the next things
that you think CRISPR
will be able to influence?
And I am also curious, I think
everyone watching is curious
what's the next frontier for you?
Where do you think this can go next?
What's your research now on?
- Well, I'll start with
the first question.
There are a few thousand human
diseases that are well known
to be caused by a single genetic mutation
a single gene whose correction could lead
to a therapeutic benefit.
So those are I think obvious
initial targets for CRISPR.
The big challenge is the
challenge of delivery
which means how do we
get the CRISPR molecules
into the cells that need editing?
So the example of sickle
cell is a good one
because it provides a
way to do the editing
outside of the patient because of
the need to edit the cells of the blood
which can be easily found and
then taken into the laboratory
and edited and then replaced.
But what if we want to
edit a gene in brain cells
or in heart cells or muscle cells
it's a lot harder to
do that in the patient.
So that's, I think in many
ways where the bottleneck is
right now in the genome editing field.
So, in terms of the next maybe
near term targets for CRISPR,
I certainly think other blood
disorders will be addressed
as well as diseases of the eye
because this is again a
tissue where potentially
one can deliver the CRISPR
molecules locally by injection.
And maybe in the not too distant future
maybe a few years from now,
we'll see therapies for
muscular dystrophy coming along.
There are a number of groups and companies
that are working very
actively on muscular dystrophy
because of the potential
to deliver CRISPR molecules
into muscle cells.
And doing that using viruses
that specifically go into muscle cells.
And in terms of my own research,
I'm continuing to work on
the fundamentals of CRISPR
and understanding how it works.
But we're also engaging increasingly
in this challenge of delivery.
Because I think that for me as a scientist
I really wanna see this
technology be affordable
and available to everybody
around the world that needs it.
That's a tall order, but I think one step
towards doing that is making
sure that we can deliver it
into a cell type where
it can be beneficial.
- It's important to
note, we've talked a lot
about the implications for
CRISPR to kind of change
and maybe, quote improve,
but maybe sometimes
people can go rogue.
It also allows us to
understand one of main things
where we're so afraid
to edit gene genetics
is because it's such a complex system,
but obviously outside of humans,
you could do it in other
models and other animals
or in bacteria.
You can now edit and kind
of run, kind of AB testing
the way that you do in software.
Like, what if I change this?
How does that happen?
What if I change this?
What if I change this and this is?
Are you seeing that type of
research accelerate dramatically
because of CRISPR?
- Hugely, hugely, I mean,
this is something that
over the last eight years we've just seen
research taking off at
an extraordinary pace,
doing exactly what you just said Sal.
So because now that we
have this technology
for precise manipulation
of one or even many genes
in cells in the laboratory,
it's an incredible tool.
It means that we can now manipulate genes
and understand gene functions
in ways that previously would
have been very difficult
or in some cases impossible
really to figure out.
- In the time we have, we
have a lot of young people
watching and a lot of
parents of young people
have this question from
Facebook, Carol Smith Kapur,
I'll paraphrase, they have a
son who wants to do what...
Actually I just lost the question.
Well, I'll paraphrase.
Who wants to go into this type of a field?
What would you say to a young person
who's fascinated by this?
I've heard people say
what computing has been the
last two or three decades
the next two or three decades
is going to be all about
genetic technology.
What do you recommend to
someone in high school?
What should they focus on?
What should they study?
What are good majors to be in?
And what do you think
the careers will be like
as you go in the decades ahead?
- Thanks for the question, Carol.
there's so many
opportunities for young folks
who are getting into science right now
or thinking about that.
Is science the right career for me?
And like you said, Sal, I think,
it's just I think many of us
that are working in this field
feel that there are just
exploding opportunities.
There's many things that
were difficult to do
even a year or two ago
that we're now able to do
as scientists in terms of our research.
So for students, I would
say, pursue your...
I always tell my own students, my own son,
pursue your passions.
And if it's biology that you
get really excited about,
pursue that, if it's chemistry,
for me it was chemistry
in those early days.
And wanting to understand
how molecules work.
And I've always found for myself that
by really following my own kind
of gut feelings about things
what I felt really passionately
excited about studying,
that has always led me in
interesting directions.
Not always directions that I
could have predicted either
which kind of makes science fun.
- Absolutely, and maybe
in my last question
I am curious, how does it feel?
Do you ever sit there
and look in the mirror
and say, yeah, I just
changed humanity forever.
- Well, I have to say that
when we were first doing this
research in the laboratory
there were a number of moments for me
where I was kind of
pinching myself and saying,
is this really happening?
It seemed kind of fantastical
to think that bacteria
had evolved a system for detecting viruses
that we could then
figure out how it worked
in the laboratory.
And that that insight would
then allow us to harness it
as a powerful technology.
So, it was really an incredible experience
to be involved in that.
And yeah, again to me, I would just,
again getting back to why I'm a scientist
and why I think it's
such a wonderful career
for students that are thinking about this,
it's a way to continue to have
the kind of curiosity driven
passions that you have
when you're growing up and you get to
as a scientist people still pay me to
ask questions and try to
figure out how things work.
It's really a fun career.
- Well, you can feel the energy.
And I mean, I think it makes sense
'cause you are literally
changing the world.
And there are people
speaking hyperbolic terms
about a lot of things,
but what you have done,
I do think in 100 or 200 years,
a lot of what we're doing
in our current time might be forgotten,
but this is gonna be one of
these things that will change
hopefully and I believe
forever, positively humanity.
So thank you so much for your work
and thank you for joining
us and inspiring us.
- Thanks for inviting me
so Sal, great to be here.
- So thanks everyone for joining.
If you couldn't tell, I was
a little bit star struck
for anyone who's followed
what's been going on
in biology and chemistry
over the last several years.
What Jennifer's work with her colleagues
it's gonna be a big deal
and you're only gonna hear
more and more about it.
So look, I encourage you
if any of what we said is confusing
definitely you can review
the foundations on Khan
Academy on your chemistry
and the biology on Khan Academy.
But I encourage you to look into that
because I have a feeling in many fields
especially if you're going
into biotech or medicine
of the war Jennifer's work and CRISPR
is going to be a central element.
So it's a good thing to get smart on.
So with that, thanks so much for joining.
And I will see all of
y'all I believe next week.
I live day to day, I don't
know what I'm doing tomorrow.
But I will see you all, have a good day.